my husband okay and he passed yes okay
so then that means that the 12th of a
month or the 12th month December is
going to be connected to you as well
usually birthday or
anniversary and then connected to your
dad there would be the same thing I said
to the first one my dad's birthday was
December okay and then the woman that
would be connected to your dad would be
the sister or your mom there's a
mother-in-law it's the same my mom's
passed as well okay so before your mom
passed was there a disconnect in the
energy like did you not have the
opportunity to see her talk to her or
connect with
her oh my God I I missed it by an hour
okay so you were either stuck in traffic
or stuck at appointment or stuck in
something that you couldn't be there yes
yes okay and you're one of three kids
yes okay and out of the three kids two
are similar and one is different and
somebody's an Aquarian like my daughter
where there's a birthday correct yes
okay and then they lost a son or a
younger male as well or somebody here
lost a son my um my mother did okay so
your brother is with them cuz they tell
me to talk about the Sun and then there
was a chromosomal genetic defect correct
oh my God yes okay cuz they're making me
feel like I need to acknowledge the
chromosomal genetic defect and then they
say they they're telling me to tell you
Jason Jackson Jason jce Jace Jace or
Jaden somebody's got a connection to
either Jay it sounds like Jace Jason
Jace
jce I want to say Jason but I want to
stop myself like jaase so maybe somebody
goes by a name that sounds like Chase or
they sound sounds like Jace I don't know
have to think on that one and that's not
for you right
Tracy actually we're not pulling you in
Tracy just got like some negative yucky
energy just to be really really clear
like let me just be really really clear
like I have to swim in that pool and if
you want me to do that that's got to go
away um which
energ I earn my title to the bigest
douche um so there's a reference for you
Wendy I need to talk about the keyboard
and the piano so do you know why my
husband played the keyboard in the piano
okay but did you sit down and try to
play it oh always okay so do you have
the one that you can record the stuff on
it no so I want to talk about what would
be the recording the audio recording or
keeping something that was recorded okay
yes okay yes do you want me to tell you
as long as you understand it they can
debrief you right and just to be clear
for everybody watching we don't know
each other right never met you in my
life okay I didn't even see you walk in
okay um I I I want you to know that one
of the things that's important about
information coming through validation
coming through evidence being shown it
is to show you that there's a survival
of Consciousness that life and love are
Eternal that they're with you but most
importantly that we're still here in the
school of life and there are lessons
that we're learning and you're feeling
stuck you're feeling like you're stuck
in a certain place and you're feeling
like how did I get left here you're
feeling isolated you're feeling orphaned
you're feeling alone right so one of the
things I want people to know and I know
this is hard I I want you to know that
you're not alone you have a good support
structure and you're concerned about
relationships with kids so I don't know
if you're concerned about working on
your own relationship with kids but
everything goes back to communication
right so I I I wrote a book called
infinite Quest and my daughter sitting
here I wrote it for my kids it was the
how to develop your psychic abilities
not to do readings but to learn about
energy kind of book and I in in it I
talk about how we how we should learn
our our breed right each person we meet
is a breed so if I said oh this person's
a Chihuahua you immediately get an idea
of who the person is this person is a
Great Dane you get an idea of who the
person is so from an energy standpoint
if we look at someone's astrological
chart right even like the big three
which I'm not an astrologer but I pay
attention to it their sun sign their
moon sign and their ascendant if folks
look at that they can get an idea of how
to communicate with the people that are
in their lives and understand maybe
what's like happening like what's
happening around them now did you say
your husband's pasted yes okay so you
either marry twice or I'm supposed to
talk about the second marriage or
renewing of the vows cuz I'm seeing
interlocking wedding bands so what's the
what's the interlocking wedding bands my
only marriage so he's telling me to talk
about interlocking wedding bands that
only means two things to me it means
that somebody was either married
previously right or there was a renewal
of vows in some way he was married
before okay and then if I said to you
Adam or Adele or a name with an a where
is that connected to him or you I have a
niece Adam Adele Amanda um um nope I
hear the D with I hear the vowel and
then the D so think like Adele Adam I
want to put it around your husband so if
he has the friend that's passed or if
he's connected to somebody that's oh
Adele and remember there's a remember
there's the the the there was a person
that died they they fell off a bridge
they fell off a building somebody fell
off of something I fall off the time I'm
just kidding no no no this is a big fall
um this is a really really big fall off
a bridge yeah somebody either had a
somebody either they either jumped from
something or somebody fell this a high
fall it's a high to low
fall could that be mentally nope this
would be somebody who had a they either
jumped and passed they fell off a
building they were in a small plane
crash high to low something that's high
to low Tracy not for you no
okay I'm
waiting maybe I have a question does she
have a teeth thing going on maybe you're
just did you not hear her yeah she's got
that and she had the insurance thing I
guess I can't okay okay that makes a lot
of sense why I was confused okay the a
name it I do know where it's connected
to me because is it like Chase or Jace
it's chai chai
CH uh yeah that's I'm I'm not gonna get
that I I don't know if I pronouncing it
right but it is the CH H uh uh uh do I
tell you nope as as long as you as long
as you get it you can tell me later um I
just want to make sure that I'm not
bringing somebody else that's here into
this but somebody feels like they passed
because of a fall like they passed
because it was a high to low fall so
that to me would be somebody who either
jumped
oh this is not a minor fall this is a
big fall this isn't like somebody fell
in the hospital and died this is but
from down the stairs yeah this is a high
to low fall yeah and that's how they
passed like as a result of that sort of
that was part of If the fall was the
beginning of the decline of the person
and we see that as being the moment
absolutely If the fall is not that then
I can't let you claim that no it was the
second thing that added to it not it
this is somebody who literally either
fell off a bridge fell off a building
jumped off a bridge jumped off a
building or they were in a plane crash
something that would be high and then
they were low and that's what causes
their passing um I don't know if there's
somebody else in that room that this
applies to that doesn't apply to me okay
so whenever I'm reading for some
somebody and I hit that impass I'll
always be pushy like I was with Tracy to
make sure and if everybody's listening
that's back there if if this does apply
to you come to the mic and tell me it
applies to you you know if if that is
true I don't think we're talking about
somebody that's on the watching this I
think somebody here is doing well in
your circle here in this building where
we are okay has somebody who passed that
way and I don't feel like it's going
that direction I feel like it's still
going this direction so if there's
anybody that's out in this section here
that has that like they may not want to
they may be getting you know if somebody
jumped or something they may not want to
you know mental health is my little Soap
Box they may not want to come forward
and share that
right the guy that's sitting next to you
do you guy you work here all the time
you yeah do you have that somewhere
connected through you like is there some
story where somebody had a high to low
passing not for me no you sure yeah and
no Michael connected to
you no
just tell me to say Mike Mikey Mike m
Mickey there's like an M
name i don't no is it Wendy Wendy what
yeah now that when you said that name
now I'm remember one of my mother's best
friend's son committed suicide and his
name was Mickey okay and the way that
I'm describing
it now like I know this is like
splitting hairs here Wendy but is did he
pass in a high to low passing like where
he yeah he killed himself jumping okay
yeah so this is your family's way of
letting you know that they know that
you're here and this is one of the
things where you know I did a I did a
radio show in South Africa and you know
I always do readings where they people
call in and I answer the call well the
gentleman there brought people into the
studio and it was like I was all over
the place it was like I couldn't I can't
keep track of like once you're not
controlling that side you're just yeah I
just kind of I kind of just go with what
I'm getting and hopefully makes sense
Wendy what what are you thinking I'm
just blown away I mean I'm I'm like I'm
ter you know
because it's just but does it help it
does help because I believe that there
is you know a crossing over of people
and that they have give you signs in
some way and I do I believe that I've
always believed
that
d